[Musique]
nouveau numéro de votre rendez vous
consacré à la présidentielle en france
france 2022 l'heure du choix désormais
donc tous les soirs du lundi au vendredi
à 20h10 heure de paris avec vous ashwin
verdien bonsoir bonsoir claire et j - 4
avant le premier tour oui à ce stade
clair un électeur sur trois on sait
qu'on de s'abstenir d'autres ont
l'intention de se déplacer dans leurs
bureaux de vote mais pour jeter un
bulletin blanc dans l'urne autre moyen
d'exprimer sa désaffection envers le
monde politique un vote qui toutefois
n'est pas reconnu en france pour info
lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle en 2017 il y avait eu
plus de 3 millions de bulletins blancs
soit huit et demi pour cent des votants
un record face à ce constat plusieurs
candidats parmi lesquels jean lassalle
propose la reconnaissance donc de ce
vote dans leur programme cette question
et tout le reste de l'actu politique
dans le récap de fort en roseau et
fabrice perron
c'est l'histoire d'un insoumis
démultipliée
c'est désormais sa signature jean luc
mélenchon et simultanément aux quatre
coins de la france douze villes vingt
mille personnes réunies l'occasion
d'envoyer un message aux électeurs de
marine le pen elle qui selon les
sondages lui barrent toujours la route
du second tour
écoutez vous au les fâcher qu'elle pas
facho à la fin où ça vous même cette
histoire de porte d'essayer porter cette
femme au pouvoir
où il trouve et vous quoi que ce soit
dans ce qu'elle dit ou ce qu'elle fait
qu'ils ne soient pas entièrement teinté
d'une sorte de mépris
de classe du mépris emmanuel macron en a
t'il pour france 2 une chose est sûre la
chaîne publique grincent des dents après
une énième bouderie du président
candidat favorable qui plus est à une
suppression de la redevance j'avais une
question à vous poser d'abord ça va si
vous avez des nouvelles de ma cran parce
que on pensait qu'il ne lui a pas fallu
longtemps pour créer le buzz
l'anticapitaliste philippe poutou ne
devrait pas passer ses vacances avec
eric zemmour
2200 de parole avant d'accueillir eric
zemmour qui se prépare en coulisses et
qui va prendre la suite vous allez du
fasciste raciste il a accusé d'agression
sexuelle
sourire en coin du candidat de
reconquête cible de choix de ses rivaux
comme jean luc mélenchon pique signée
marine le pen on a deux candidats que
son hémiplégie qu il y en a qui ne
parlent que de protection sociale et
l'autre qui ne parlent que de protection
civilisationnel et mois précisément je
suis la candidate de toutes les
protections le casse du siècle
ce ne devrait pas être ce dimanche pour
lui jean lassalle a une envie redonner
le pouvoir au peuple
la meilleure manière de le faire c'est
de comptabiliser complètement et de
tenir compte absolument du vote blanc ce
qui fait que dimanche prochain compte
tenu de ce que je vois et j'entends dans
la campagne
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
et puis ce rebondissement dans la ferme
à qinze est on appris qu'aujourd'hui
mais le parquet national financiers a
ouvert une enquête préliminaire le 31
mars pour blanchiment aggravé de fraude
fiscale à l'encontre du cabinet de
conseil eric zemmour fabien roussel ou
nicolas dupont aignan salue cette
décision cette affaire ne cesse de
prendre de l'ampleur depuis la
publication par le sénat d'un rapport
sur le recours croissant à des cabinets
de conseil privé par l'état et sur leur
influence sur les politiques publiques
et notre coup d'oeil quotidien aux
sondages maintenant elle jour après jour
l'écart se resserre entre le président
sortant et la candidate du rassemblement
national selon ipsos oprah steria
emmanuel macron est crédité toujours de
27% des intentions de vote 22% pour
marine le pen qui gagne donc un point et
demi par rapport à hier jean luc
mélenchon gagne un demi point à 17% eric
zemmour lui est en baisse d'un point et
demi à huit et demi pour cent et
toujours 8 pour valérie kress du côté
des petits candidats maintenant fabien
roussel est à trois et demi pourcent
jean lassalle à deux et demi et nicolas
dupont aignan à 2% nicolas dupont aignan
qui par ailleurs tient son grand meeting
ce soir dans le 15e arrondissement de
paris quai de grenelle où l'on retrouve
tout de suite notre envoyé spécial
clovis casali bonsoir clovis quel est
l'état d'esprit des militants sur place
le candidat de tambours de vous la
france est juste derrière moi il en
train de prononcer les derniers mots de
son discours nicolas dupont aignan
particulièrement offensif ce soir en
particulier contre emmanuel macron
entendu la foule scander d'ailleurs
macron en prison et du mot aignan
déclaré qu'il faut nettoyer l'elysée ils
ont tué des français ils n'ont pas
soignée et tout ça pour l'appât du gain
et pour des conflits d'intérêts vous
l'aurez compris les grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques comme pfizer dans le
viseur de nicolas dupont aignan le
candidat de debout la france qui a aussi
parlé de phr excite fréq site c'est bien
sûr aussi le rêve de son bras droit un
ancien bras droit
le pen et c'est florian philippot
florian philippot qui a déclaré que
comme nicolas dupont aignan il pense que
les djihadistes devraient être envoyés
sur les îles de kerguelen au beau milieu
de l'océan indien et pourquoi pas et y
envoyer macro aussi c'est ce qu'a
déclaré florian philippot alors nicolas
dupont aignan souhaite le ferez xi qu'il
souhaite reprendre l'argent donné aux
institutions européennes pour les
reverser pour retraités c'est ce qu'il a
déclaré alors nicolas dupont aignan vous
pouvez entendre là la marseillaise
derrière moi
avec la foule
on
il aurait compris beaucoup de drapeaux
français et la foule qui chantent la
marseillaise et surchauffée ce soir
c'est le dernier un meeting de la
campagne pour nicolas dupont aignan le
candidat de debout la france tout à
l'heure nous avons parlé avec ses
militants pour essayer de comprendre un
peu qu'est ce qu'ils aiment j'ai ce
candidat pourquoi ils préfèrent nicolas
dupont aignan par exemple la marine le
pen
eric zemmour marine le pen avec qu'il
avait conclu une alliance en 2017 je
m'oppose foutu d'écouter quelques
réactions de partisans de debout la
france
à
candidat le plus pur qui puisse exister
que c'est le candidat qui a le meilleur
programme
c'est un homme qui n'a pas de dette que
c'est un homme humain qui aime la france
qui aime les français il est dans la vie
commune sera en politique
regardez programme de madame le pen
programme de du poignon n'y a pas de
similitude
pour le pal dax inhalent qu'est ce
qu'elle fera on n'en sait rien un peu
plus sortir de l'europe
il voit annulé pour de bon tout ce qui
est pas ce fax inhalent et par la suite
les passé connu économiques écologiques
et climatiques parce que bientôt ils
pourront même pas aller à 500 mètres de
chez soi
merci beaucoup plus vite pour vos
précisions depuis le xvème
arrondissement de paris merci aussi à
xavier martin et qui vous accompagnent
oui on va maintenant parler d'un thème
qui a été totalement négligé pendant
cette campagne c'est celui du
réchauffement climatique
oui ce thème n'a vraiment pas réussi à
s'imposer et pourtant il y a urgence
absolue comme nous l'a encore rappelé le
dernier rapport du giec le groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat rapport donc
publié lundi dernier son constat est
alarmant une nouvelle fois il nous reste
moins de 3 ans pour inverser la courbe
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
espérer limiter le réchauffement à un
degré et demi en 2050 c'était je vous le
rappelle l'objectif de l'accord de paris
de 2015 on en parle ce soir avec notre
spécialiste environnement de marina bay
bonsoir marina bonsoir l'écologie dont
qui n'est pas du tout au coeur de cette
campagne présidentielle voilà et à quoi
on le ressent et bien regarder le score
de yannick jadot avec ses intentions de
vote qui sont à 6 petits pourcents qui
plafonne alors que pourtant on le sait
les thématiques portées par les
écologistes est bien sont de plus en
plus présente dans la société française
en théorie les français sont tous un peu
d'accord qu'il va falloir lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique et bien ça
ne se voit pas du tout dans le score de
yannick jadot à 6% alors comment ça se
fait eh bien il faut dire que dans cette
campagne on parle beaucoup de plusieurs
choses on part de tout sauf d'écologie
on parle de pouvoir d'achat on parle
évidemment de la guerre en ukraine de la
sécurité énergétique des thèmes régalien
et beaucoup disent que yannick jadot
peine à incarner cela donc c'est un
agenda médiatique qui est fort peu
favorable aux écologistes et puis il
faut le dire sa campagne à lui elle
s'appuie sur la sympathie la proximité
yannick jadot et souriant et facile
d'accès alors qu'en ce moment en pleine
guerre en ukraine et bien les français
ils ont besoin de quoi ils veulent quoi
ils veulent une stature de chef de chef
d'état assez éloignée il faut dire de
l'image car yannick jadot en ce moment
il le résume lui même yannick jadot à
nos confrères du monde je dois encore
lever des doutes sur la capacité des
écologistes à gouverner la france je
trouve que c'est assez bien résumé puis
un dernier élément qui ne faut pas
oublier c'est la présence de jean luc
mélenchon qui est le candidat qui monte
jean luc mélenchon qui est très assis
sur les politiques écologiques il a il a
beaucoup de deux verres dans son
programme et ça c'est depuis longtemps
ça date pas d'hier donc très clairement
jean luc mélenchon aussi il prend
quelques petits points à yannick jadot
et dans le détail ça donne quoi son
programme à yannick jadot alors on va
regarder ensemble avec quelques mesures
phares on a évidemment cette proposition
clé 100 % d'énergie renouvelable ça
c'est pas étonnant avec un maximum
d'éoliennes 3000 éolienne terrestre
avant 2027 240 kilomètres carrés de
panneaux solaires et puis évidemment à
la sortie du nucléaire avec fermer les
réacteurs qui ne sont plus en état deux
cent mille emplois créés aussi dans la
rénovation énergétique la fin des
voitures thermiques d'ici 2030
l'interdiction aussi de certains vols en
avion ce qui lui semble le plus
déraisonnable un paris lille par exemple
ou un paris-lyon diviser par deux les
engrais et les pesticides 2000 d'ici
2027 vous vous en souvenez ça faisait
aussi partie de la campagne des manuels
macro est bien là yannick jadot propose
d'interdire le glyphosate de verrouiller
ce dos c est aussi les néonicotinoïdes
tueur d'abeilles et puis évidemment des
propositions pour lutter contre la
pollution de l'air qui s'aggrave d'année
en année en france tout ça avec de gros
moyens financiers
à la clé il vient pas les mains vides
yannick jadot lorsque ce qui est
intéressant c'est que par rapport à ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure quand
on regarde toutes ces thématiques la
plupart des français en réalité ils sont
assez d'accord avec ce que propose
yannick jadot avec un petit et pourtant
ça se ressent pas dans les sondages il
ya quand même un petit bémol qui est
cette sortie du nucléaire qui n'est
plébiscité que par 30 % de français
alors il ya une certitude tout même avec
tout cela avec ce programme dont je
viens de vous parler c'est que yannick
jadot attention avec jean luc mélenchon
et le candidat regarder qui se rapproche
le plus des objectifs de l'accord de
paris alors on n'a aucun candidat un qui
est très proche tout ça parce que
certains la plupart en réalité des
programmes ne contiennent pas assez de
détails pour savoir comment on va faire
pour la faire cette cause cette
transition énergétique mais regardez les
deux qui sont les plus proches et bien
c'est bien yannick jadot évidemment sans
surprise et jean luc mélenchon ça c'est
une étude qui a été faite par un think
tank qui s'appelle le chiffre project
avec france info pas de doute yannick
jadot il est bien dans le vert mais ça
ne suffira sans doute pas à atteindre le
deuxième tour merci beaucoup marina pour
cet éclairage donc sur la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique dans les
programmes des candidats et donc
précisément sur celui de yannick jadot
suite à présent de notre série de
portraits il est l'un des deux candidats
trotskistes de cette présidentielle le
leader du nouveau parti anticapitaliste
philippe poutou détonne par son franc
parler et ses idées radicales c'est la
troisième fois qu'il se présente et
malgré ses scores toujours dérisoire il
profite à chaque fois du scrutin
présidentiel pour se faire le porte-voix
de toutes les luttes anticapitalistes
donc écologiste féministe antiraciste
son portrait est signée fadil bayat
dans certains rêvent d'un destin
présidentiel philippe poutou lui assume
la fonction suprême il n'en veut pas
pourtant depuis 2012 il est le visage du
nouveau parti anticapitaliste il prend
la relève du célèbre facteur olivier
besancenot
candidat
c'est philippe avec son vécu
[Applaudissements]
le succès n'est pas au rendez vous avec
un score de 1 15% à la présidentielle le
candidat anticapitaliste appelle du bout
des lèvres à voter françois hollande
nous le disons qu'avant
s'ils pensaient en rester là en 2017 il
est à nouveau investie par le npa
désormais connue du grand public
philippe poutou prend goût à l'exercice
et sort les griffes notamment face à
françois fillon et marine le pen quand
noël est convoqué par la police ne vous
voyez par exemple on a pas d'immunité
ouvrière désolé on y va voilà vous avez
une chance le système
tant mieux pour vous mais le candidat
reste cantonné à 1% des suffrages après
l'élection philippe poutou s'illustre
par son combat contre la fermeture de
l'usiné ford à blanquefort où il est
salarié malgré le soutien du ministre de
l'économie ford refuse d offres de
reprise et met la clé sous la porte en
2019 philippe poutou est licencié en
2020 première victoire électorale
l'ouvrier au chômage fait ses premiers
pas en tant qu élue au conseil municipal
de bordeaux nous on pense effectivement
que notre véritable force c'est pas
juste les trois élus parce qu'à trois
élus on n'est pas fous on sait qu'on ne
pèse pas plus lourd que trois autres
élus d'un autre parti mais par contre
c'est le lien qu'on va faire avec tout
le monde associatif syndicalistes avec
même y compris les salariés de la ville
et puis tout simplement le mouvement
social une responsabilité nouvelle qui
ne l'empêchent pas cette année d'être
candidat pour la troisième fois à
l'élection présidentielle philippe
poutou de 500 parrainages in extremis et
il est prêt à en découdre boudé par
certains médias le candidat l'assurent
il ira jusqu'au bout pour faire exister
ses idées son rêve mettre fin au
capitalisme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on en reparle avec notre reporter
karina chahbour qui couvrent pour nous
cette campagne présidentielle bonsoir
karina philippe poutou un candidat qui
détonne c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est vraiment le candidat du franc
parler pour lui la langue de bois mais
ça n'est pas son truc il aime les
saillies il est réputé pour une certaine
forme d'ironie pour une répartie
toujours avec des formules bien senties
il a une certaine gouaille qui lui vient
sûrement de son passé d'ouvrier et de
syndicalistes dans le secteur automobile
il a d'ailleurs reçu ces dernières
heures le soutien du chanteur populaire
renault mais son projet il est
clairement radical vous l'avez déjà un
peu abordé son ennemi c'est clairement
le capitalisme les politiques qu'il juge
ultra libérale et antisociales son idéal
c'est la révolution il s'inspire en cela
du bolchévique à léon trotski il défend
à la fois les ouvriers et tout un tas de
cause traditionnellement classé à gauche
que ce soit l'antiracisme l'antifascisme
vous l'avez dit mais également le
féminisme ou encore l'écologie d'un
point de vue politique lui il veut
abroger la vème république il veut en
finir avec la fonction de président de
la présidence de la république qui selon
lui considère trop de pouvoirs il veut
aussi fermé le sénat une assemblée de
notables élus par des notables il veut
instaurer un système de proportionnelle
intégrale et il veut aussi accorder le
droit de vote à toutes les élections
pour tous les résidents étrangers il
veut d'ailleurs régulariser l'ensemble
des sans-papiers une prône ce qu'il
appelle la décolonisation des
territoires d'outre-mer et de la corse
au nom du droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux mêmes et qu'on est il de ces
propositions pour l'économie car henin
va vous savez un slogan c'est nos vies
plus que leurs profits un slogan qui
d'ailleurs a été détournée volée par le
président candidat à la défense lors de
son meeting le week-end dernier c'est
c'est une charme ces mesures il souhaite
en finir avec des productions des
productions une juge inutiles comme par
exemple dans l'armement dans la
publicité il veut réduire fortement le
transport aérien après qu'il veut
saucier lisez une économie autour de
grands pôles publics et de renforcer les
services publics il a d'ailleurs prévu
de créer un million de postes de
fonctionnaires supplémentaires s'il
était élu il veut interdire tout
simplement les licenciements réduire le
temps de travail à 32 heures
hebdomadaires
il veut instaurer une sixième semaine de
congés payés la retraite à 60 ans et
instauré le smig relever le smic à 1800
euros net par mois par mois oui
absolument donc une certaine façon de
travailler moins pour gagner plus il
veut également réquisitionner les
logements vides et sur l'énergie il
prône la fermeture de toutes les
centrales nucléaires d'ici à 2030 de et
parvenir à 100 % ne renouvelables en
2050 mais sans expliquer ce qui se
passera entre ces deux dates
il veut également exproprier le géant
pétrolier total
enfin on l'a dit c'est sa troisième
campagne
présidentielle les deux fois précédentes
il n'avait guère atteint plus de 1,2 en
vient de 15% mais pour lui l'essentiel
est ailleurs puisque c'est effectivement
plus une campagne de témoignage où il
s'agit de profiter de cette tribune de
ces quelques semaines pour faire parler
de lui il a d'ailleurs déjà laissé
entendre qu'une fois cet épisode passé
et bien ils chercheraient du travail et
les poursuivra la lutte merci beaucoup
car henin pour ce point donc sur la
personnalité le programme de philippe
poutou et c'est tout pour ce soir merci
beaucoup h rennes verdien vous retrouve
demain soir à 20h10 à seulement 2 paris
c'est la fin de france 2022 l'heure du
choix à demain h rennes a retrouvé cette
émission bien sûr en sur notre site
internet
www.francebillet.com et sur les réseaux
sociaux reste avec nous parler direct
continue on se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour un nouveau journal
[Musique]